[Musica]
per me l'opera d'arte è quella che ti
cambia il modo di pensare
quella che ti entra nel midollo è un
momento salvifico
Daniela lucangeli
logica psicologa specialista in scienze
cognitive in un Ted di qualche anno fa
ha detto che in ogni istante attimo
secondo nel cervello di un bambino c'è
un impulso che si ripete all'infinito
che si moltiplica e questo impulso
cambia l'informazione genetica
questi attimi quindi hanno un presente e
un futuro
nella mente di una persona con demenza
senile questi attimi non si sa che fine
facciano
sono in una specie di magma che a volte
emerge a volte rimane lì a fare delle
bolle
c'è
un momento in Guerre Stellari nel primo
che poi è diventato il quarto in cui Lux
Skywalker deve sparare per uccidere la
morte nera e tutto quel quella la palla
bianca in cui vivono tutti i cattivi e
hobby ho anche nodi gli dice
Used Force usa la forza falla falla
emergere questa forza è l'istinto
l'istinto che lo porta a togliere il
mirino e a sparare Ecco questo attimo in
cui lui si affida al suo istinto Secondo
me è l'attimo in cui l'artista si affida
alla sua intuizione è un'intuizione a
cui lui si avvinghia per portare al
mondo
un pensiero che lui ha attraverso penna
coltello accetta
pennello scalpello qualsiasi cosa
l'opera d'arte di cui parlo io è quella
cinematografica perché è quella che
conosco un pochino meglio Vado in
disordine perché a me l'ordine non è
stato concesso
uno dei primi cambiamenti che ricordo mi
è arrivato guardando Toro scatenato un
film bellissimo del 1980 di Scorsese Io
sono stati educata a rispettare la legge
Quindi quando
Jack La Motta viene messo in prigione
sono rimasta sconvolta perché quest'uomo
non faceva come avrei fatto io se avessi
ricevuto una condanna cioè sarei
rientrata Ligia dentro la mia cella No
lui nella cella non ci vuole entrare c'è
bisogno di due persone che lo spingono
lo riempiono di parolacce e pugni Perché
lui si ribella ecco per me questo
momento della ribellione di quest'uomo
ha fatto un click un primo Click
un altro click mi è arrivato con un
altro film straordinario un giocatore di
football americano a un certo punto si
ritrova in un ambiente che non capisce
cosa sia Pensa sto sognando che cos'è
allora lui è in un prepara Paradiso e
deve salire su un aereo le anime lì sono
tutte pronte per andare in paradiso
mansuete come avrei fatto anch'io ma lui
no perché deve giocare la finale di
campionato E assolutamente non può
salire su quell'aereo è talmente fa
tante storie che arriva il capo degli
Angeli e controlla la scheda
effettivamente
quest'uomo non era morto
l'angelo che l'ha prelevato dal corpo ha
presunto che quest'uomo fosse morto e
l'ha tolto dal suo corpo e l'ha portato
nel prepara Paradiso Insomma allora no
io non ci sto io devo giocare alla
finale di campionato Allora anche qui
click il cervello fa
se una cosa non mi torna lo devo dire
anche se sono in paradiso Cioè quel
detto Toscano che dice Se non chiedi non
avrai se chiedi forse siccome è
importante che ognuno di noi ascolti il
proprio istinto Come si può imparare in
un film che a volte anche un'opera
d'arte e L'artista è generoso travasa la
sua idea in un film in un film Una scena
un pezzo di vita uno è un quadro
qualsiasi cosa io parlo dei film però
può rispondere a domande che non
sappiamo neanche di avere in testa
c'è un altro film meraviglioso Cast away
lo conoscete tutti un aereo precipita
nell'oceano Pacifico una persona riesce
a sopravvivere e riesce a fare 500
miglia su un gommone ad arrivare su
un'isola deserta
per impara a fare il fuoco a catturare i
granchi a mangiare qualsiasi cosa a
proteggersi a curarsi da solo riesce
addirittura ad evadere da quest'isola
Ma qual è la cosa ancora più pazzesca di
questo film di dzemakis che comunque è
un inno alla vita alla voglia di
sopravvivere di quest'uomo che è
addirittura per non stare solo parla con
un pallone
che questa storia non è una storia solo
fisica cioè l'opera d'arte qui supera se
stessa l'aereo che cade è una delusione
è una persona che muore è una
separazione è una depressione è una
qualsiasi cosa l'isola È quel posto in
cui noi ci andiamo a rintanare dove
dobbiamo rimparare a fare tutto da capo
ad apprezzare la vita ad accettare le
nostre difficoltà a farci forza tutti i
giorni
Io penso che ognuno di noi è capitato da
ogni cosa si può imparare e il maestro
arriva quando l'allievo è pronto Io
spero sempre di avere il mio cervello
pronto ad acchiappare qualsiasi pezzetto
di cose che mi dia delle intuizioni per
migliorare me stessa
un'altra persona che deve evadere a
questo punto invece non da un'isola ma
da una realtà è il direttore il
direttore del director il regista di un
film che si chiama Sullivan e il film si
chiama hai dimenticato e in americano si
chiama sullivans Travel
è un regista di commedia di successo
però vuole dimostrare che non è solo un
regista di commedia e che può fare anche
un film impegnato e vuole raccontare i
barboni i dimenticati e si immerge
talmente tanto in questa cosa che perde
il controllo della situazione si ritrova
in una colonia penale
e arriva un pezzo di giornale da cui
scopre di essere dato per un morto
quindi nessuno lo cerca e lui cosa fa
prima Beh si dispera e poi dice non può
finire così non posso proprio così come
il pensatore di non può finire così non
può finire così lui applica una regola
della sceneggiatura
da sceneggiatore alla sua vita e quindi
si fa venire un'idea per finire questo
film che però la sua vita e in questo
modo riesce a uscire di prigione e tutto
finisce bene l'altra cosa che mi piace
molto che è un pezzo di opera d'arte
però di vita è del regista che ha fatto
questo film che si chiama Preston
sturgest era un famosissimo
sceneggiatore negli anni quaranta E in
quegli anni ad Hollywood o Iri
sceneggiatore o ai regista allora lui
vuole fare questo film Perché lui si è
innamorato di questa sceneggiatura che
ha scritto ma alla produzione la
Paramount immagino questi uomini col
sigaro abbastanza arrogante più grandi
produzione dell'epoca dice di no E
allora lui lancia una sfida opera d'arte
io vivendo la sceneggiatura un dollaro
se mi fate dirigere questo film e lo fa
e riesce a dirigere il suo film osa
bisogna usare Bisogna bisogna credere in
se stessi bisogna avere rispetto per le
cose che fai farle con amore e
difenderle perché nessuno come lui
l'avrebbe diretto È un film
straordinario
10 anni dopo Questo film è un film un
altro film in bianco e nero per me è il
bianco e nero è è più bello dei colori è
proprio è il massimo il bianco e nero è
eterno qui siamo
fuori da Kyoto alla porta di Rushmore si
chiama questa porta la storia è
un racconto caleidoscopico
della morte di un Samurai e del Supra di
sua moglie sono tre punti di vista anzi
quattro anzi secondo me di più Comunque
il punto di questo film è che loro
parleranno di questo evento mostruoso e
non arrivano mai alla verità la verità è
al centro ognuno dei personaggi dalla
sua versione del racconto l'effetto
rashomon una una che viene chiamato
anche
relativismo cognitivo è quello per cui
nessuno
coincide mai con l'altro cioè ci sono
sempre dei punti diversi di vista dal
tuo Questa è una cosa che a me ha
cambiato Io l'ho visto a 18 anni E
effettivamente mi pensavo molto perché
delle cose non le capivo a questo punto
visto questo film e ha cominciato a
farmi clicchi il cervello e qui l'opera
d'arte In questo film non è solo la così
il trucchetto L'invenzione del giochino
è proprio che è un film meraviglioso da
tutti i punti di vista è il primo film
in cui si inquadra il sole si dice che
questa era un tabù che mai nessuno prima
aveva osato infrangere entriamo in un
invece in tutt'altro ambiente in un
ambiente chiuso in un ambiente
che potrebbe sembrare quello anche della
persona con la difficoltà con un deficit
mentale una persona che non riesce a
uscire dal suo ieri che continua nel
domani a trovarsi nello ieri Anzi una
persona in un film e due persone in un
altro sono più o meno lo stesso giochino
parlo del giorno della marmotta e di
Palm Springs sono due commedie Deli
base in cui c'è una specie di serpente
che si morde la coda queste persone non
riescono a uscire da questa giornata e
fanno di tutte La ripetono mille volte
perché non riescono a uscire da questa
giornata perché non sono amare Perché
raccontano se stessi agli altri perché
non vedono gli altri perché
continuano a fare uno stesso errore che
probabilmente anche noi nella vita
facciamo Per questo a volte ci
ritroviamo sempre nella stessa
problematica perché non abbiamo dato
abbastanza perché non siamo stati
abbastanza noi stessi
una persona che soffre di demenza senile
è completamente se stessa Non ha più
filtri
non sa più raccontarsi all'altro e
questa persona che io frequento
attimi un attimo dietro l'altro sono
attimi e io come Luke Skywalker devo
entrare in questo attimo devo sparare
con il mio istinto e entrare in
Quell'attimo
sto guardando un Nuovo Cinema Paradiso
e
Nuovo Cinema Paradiso film abbastanza
nostalgico a un certo punto lei ha
cominciato a sbuffare Si annoiava non
riuscivo più a renderglielo divertente
questo film è difficile renderlo
divertente
è arrivato poi la sequenza di baci una
specie di montagna russa di emozioni
lei se l'è guardata tutte e quando è
finita ha detto
quanta passione Certo che ne ho dati di
baci
[Applauso]